they had the front runner for the
Republican Party On TV and they they
debated him and that was not good enough
yeah and so they're losing audience
members for doing so yeah they that look
CNN you want to be in the cult be in the
cult if CNN reported real news they
would have tremendous ratings could you
imagine if the entire time scene existed
they were pushing back on russiagate
lies they were saying like these reports
are not true there's no evidence to
adjust it then people would be watching
them and all they had to compete with
Fox News all they had to do was tell the
truth right like you could tell an
unbiased true like factual story The the
way that Donald Trump was covered for
his entire presidency once he got into
office if you covered any other
president in the same way with that much
negative press you're going to have a
population that believes that he is evil